>> Chris: IT'S TIME FOR REDDIT
REDACTIONS.
REDDIT REDACTIONS.
A NEW WEBSITE, REDDIT COMMENT
SEARCH DOT COM, ALLOWS USERS TO
SEARCH SPECIFIC WORDS OR PHRASES
IN THEIR COMMENT HISTORY AND
DELETE THEM.
THAT'S GREAT, BECAUSE IF THERE
IS ONE THING THAT PEOPLE WHO
POST COMMENTS ON THE INTERNET
NEED, IT'S LESS ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR THEIR HATEFUL, MISSPELLED
RANTS.
SO COMEDIANS, I WANT YOU TO GIVE
ME SOME KEYWORDS FROM YOUR
REDDIT COMMENTS THAT YOU WOULD
WANT DELETED IN 60 SECONDS.
AND GO!
BRENDON.
>> MAN, ALL OF THESE COMMENT
MAKE ME WANT TO KILL THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Chris: POINTS.
RANDY.
>> INFILTRATING THE COMEDY SCENE
TO EVENTUALLY MURDER BRENDON
WALSH.
>> Chris: OKAY.
POINTS.
BRENDAN.
>> I KIND OF FANCY MYSELF THE
WHITE BILL COSBY.
>> Chris: POINTS.
YES, YOU WOULD WANT THAT
REMOVED.
EMILY.
>> ARE WHITE PEOPLE ALLOWED TO
SAY "FLEEK."
>> Chris: POINTS.
BRENDAN.
>> ANYBODY ANYONE ELSE HERE
HATE THE FBI?
>> Chris: POINTS.
EMILY.
>> GETTING NUTELLA OUT OF PUBES.
>> Chris: POINTS.
RANDY.
>> DOES ANYBODY KNOW WHERE TO
BUY A GUN? I THINK I AM FINALLY
GOING TO MURDER BRENDON WALSH.
>> Chris: POINTS.